[Applause]
[Music]
here's a question and don't cheat in
Google the answer imagine that you have
to buy a house where would be cheaper
Barcelona or Miami if you need a clue
let me tell you that both cities have
more or less the same population if we
consider their metropolitan area both
cities have beaches and a very touristy
[Music]
in addition the average salary in Miami
is almost twice the one in Barcelona and
their unemployment rate is much much
lower having said all of that many may
think that by logic Barcelona would be
cheaper than Miami
well if you're thinking that you're
actually wrong homes in Miami are 15
percent cheaper than those in Barcelona
yes dear if you were buying a house in
Spain is truly an impossible mission but
I know where you may be thinking right
now houses well they're expensive
everywhere right well yeah you you are
actually right house prices are rising
in almost every country and this is
especially surprising if we consider
that the trend is quite the opposite for
other goods we've said it already on
this channel like a thousand times
humanity is just doing better we've
practically eradicated malnutrition all
around the world our standard of living
is much higher than that of our
grandparents and this is pretty much new
among other things to the fact that the
products we consume they're getting
cheaper for instance just thirty years
ago our parents would have to save an
average month's salary to fly from
London to just Berlin
nowadays that's just history that
housing is the only element that hasn't
become more accessible indeed it's
becoming almost prohibitively expensive
in many parts of the world in this video
we're gonna focus on Spain but many of
the things we're going to review could
happen in almost any country because the
question that we're asking ourselves
today is well why is it so damn
expensive to buy a house and can we do
anything to solve this well we are going
to answer off these questions today but
first let's dive into the history the
law of the land what's the first and
most important thing we need to build a
house
well that would of course be the lands
that we're going to build it on right
well in that aspect Spain has the
perfect Drog Rafi we're talking about a
huge and relatively flat country with
many unpopulated areas other countries
for example the Netherlands do have the
very real problem of a high population
density however Spain that has plenty of
space for all of its inhabitants now
having a piece of land doesn't
necessarily mean we can use it to build
houses for example in 2011 40 percent of
the land in the capital Madrid was
considered not urbanize Abal this means
that the City Council limits
construction in these territories in
other cities such as Malaga this
percentage even rises to more than 70%
you may be wondering now well why are
there so many lands where you can't
Bill's not the answer to this lies in
municipal services you see when you
build in a residential area you need
sewers electricity new bus lines and of
course things like garbage collection
and well who's responsible for all of
these costs the City Council's that is
every taxpayer
in other words if a construction company
proposes a housing development on the
outskirts of Madrid it doesn't manage to
sell them all every local will have to
pay for a ghost areas urban services due
to all of this Town Council's have
decided to control every single detail
of where and how their municipality can
extend in Spain this is done through a
legal instrument known as the urban
ordination plans these are maps that
every city hall publishes every ten
years specifying the areas in which
someone can build because although in a
second maybe your Spanish and you're
watching this video from Spain now I
know what you might be thinking isn't
land supposed to be liberalized in Spain
indeed in 1997 jose maria as soon as
governments put out a law that involved
in theory land and liberalisation this
means that in theory all of the
country's lands became developable that
is essentially it is suitable for
construction suddenly every spanish city
grew and lots of residential areas
emerged this was the beginning of the
housing bubble but as we've mentioned
many times the devil arts in the details
[Music]
see now we said that the urban
ordination plants determine the areas
one can build on but that's not the
entire picture here it also sets the
conditions for building okay imagine
we're requesting a permit from the
Barcelona City Council to build a block
of flats on a plot that we own well the
City Council will say absolutely no
problem but you can only build 20 homes
or 15 or maybe even just 10
you need to see the problem here even if
construction is allowed housing supply
is still highly restricted and by the
way this also explains many of Spain's
corruption cases most of the scandals
that have been discovered in recent
years were revealed because developer
was bribing a town planning a council so
that instead of getting a permit for 10
houses they'd get one for twice as many
in other words the construction sector
has a larger and more perverse incentive
to essentially invest in bribes than any
other sector like for example
[Music]
anchored in the 20th century can you
guess the least productive sector of the
economy yeah as you might imagine it is
indeed construction we're talking about
a world where it's odd to find a project
actually being built by its due date and
this isn't just limited to Spain here to
give you an idea the new Apple offices
in Silicon Valley they were completed
two years later than expected and had an
extra cost of two million dollars and
the same happens with almost every house
built today one survey of british
architects found that 60% of their
buildings relate and so well now you
might be wondering well white if these
things happen at all the answer
essentially lies in a lack of innovation
of course houses today much more modern
they have better insulation that our
heating systems but the way in which
they're built is pretty much the same as
it was 50 years ago any other economic
sector it's just much more advanced for
example a car factory 60 years ago looks
nothing like a car factory today most of
the jobs are grandparents health have
simply been replaced by computer
programs machines and robots
what's the results of this well nowadays
a car has many more features and is
cheaper to make than it was 60 years ago
thanks to that now almost every family
can afford one or even two cars
however if we saw a construction project
from the 1960s with barely notice any
difference with one done today
at all same builders M trains I mean
construction companies have barely
invested at all in innovation and it's
understandable if we take their
extremely low profit margins into
accounts you heard that right
a housing developer can expect a profit
margin of two to five percent of course
if we're talking about millions of euros
2% is more than enough to make the
company's owner rich but it barely
allows them to reinvest in other things
such as research and development and if
this weren't enough there are very few
incentives to replace workers and
machines and if this was not enough
there are very few incentives to replace
workers with machines here unlike other
economic sectors working in construction
requires little training and well this
leads to a greater concentration of
low-skilled labor
so we can summarize everything like this
there's a restricted land supply which
makes property prices rise and then
there's a long and expensive and
unpredictable construction process now
what's the result of all of this
well homes in Spain have become
prohibitively expensive however almost
80% of Spaniards they manage to own
their own home so well the question is
now well how is all of this possible
well let's dive into that money for
everyone there's a basic principle in
economics things are worthwhile someone
is willing to pay for them for example
if a foreign flat in a normal
neighborhood of Madrid is worth more
than three hundred thousand euros it's
because someone can afford to pay more
than three hundred thousand euros but
how can there be so many people who can
pay so much I mean isn't Spain supposed
to be in a financial crisis didn't we
say that the average salary in Spain is
less than two thousand euros a month
[Music]
well dear viewer
the answer lies of course in the banks
three hundred thousand euros is a true
fortune for someone earning an average
salary but if one pays all that money in
comfortable installments over many many
years it would be a bit easier and so
how many yes do you think we're talking
about here ten years twenty years well
the truth is that we're talking about a
lot lot longer
40 year mortgages an exclusive and
conditional product for young people 40
years is an incredible amount of time
and it's really not uncommon in Spain to
find people who have these 40 year
mortgages and some makes a - all of this
I mean what's really the sense in that
imagine you're a bank and you grant a
couple a 40 year loan a thousand
different things can happen in four
decades which means they might not be
able to return the money so where's the
business for the banker how can the bank
risk so much when grunting alone ah well
the answer to that is in the Central
Bank ECB to keep printing billions of
euros to prop up the eurozone until 2019
you really did hear that right nowadays
Europe is producing more money than ever
however Europe does have a relatively
low inflation rate now in another visual
politic video we did explain that when
central bank's print bills prices they
tend to go up however in Europe the
opposite happens so well why is this
well that's because all of that newly
printed money that goes directly to the
banks and well what of the banks use it
for well of course that would be loans
that explains why even with relatively
low salaries most Spaniards are willing
to pay real fortunes to own a house and
what's worse prices continue to rise
unabated there will always be someone
willing to originate or take out a 40
year mortgage in other words all the
factors point to the fact that in the
long term housing will become more and
more expensive and that explains things
like this housing profitability Rises as
an investment
this means that along with the people
who buy an apartment to live in it there
are people who buy them as an investment
in other words central banks inflate
demand hands municipalities restrict
supply conclusion of all of this houses
are becoming more expensive every single
day and at this point I just want to
take the time to thank Miguel and Halfon
Seca's architectural study for helping
us understand all the details of the
world of construction and urban planning
in Spain Yale and Howell Fonseca is one
of the greatest experts of sustainable
architecture in Spain you can find more
details about him in the video
description below
and well now it's time to turn to you
how do you think this problem should be
solved do you think we should restrict
bank mortgages what about release the
lands in order to be able to build more
what kind of policies do you think would
solve this problem well please leave
your answers in the comments below and
as always let me thank the reconsider
media podcast they provided the vocals
in this episode that are not mine click
that like button below and don't forget
to subscribe for brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday and as always thank
you for watching and if you want to
learn more about politics and hear more
of my lovely voice don't forget to check
out the reconsidered podcast at
reconsider Mediacom we consider is a
podcast that challenges you to
reconsider your views by providing
context but we don't do the thinking